now with their Russia collusion
fantasies going up in flames Democrats
are trying to find new meaning in their
political lives
and to satisfy their left-wing core well
they're dabbling with socialism in
racializing almost every issue out there
imaginable but that's obviously not
enough to win in 2020 because what may
stoke their radical core repels the
white working-class voters who turned
out by the millions for Donald Trump in
2016 so I think Democrats are in
something of a conundrum here because
for all their bluster about Trump's
vulnerability they're the ones with a
big problem
unless you think steel workers and let's
say the Rust Belt are clamoring for this
message
[Applause]
now our coal miners families in West
Virginia excited about this hundreds
years of slavery and institutional
racism have caused mass inequity and
harm to black people and has held black
communities back for generations from
achieving their full potential
all right what about Union workers in
Michigan is this the approach they've
been waiting for our planet is in peril
and we need to be bold and there's a lot
of people now that are blowing back on
the Green Deal they're like oh it's
impractical oh it's too expensive oh
it's all of this if we used to govern
our dreams that way we would have never
gone to the moon all right well when
their new Oracle is part social media
Wiz and part socialist trendsetter all
Democrats risk an exodus of
working-class voters idea that you can
be poor and benefit from the color of
your skin does not compute for a lot of
people it's very painful to admit that
you had advantages well in 2016 white
voters constituted more than 74% of all
voters according to Pew Research and
remember Obama did very well with this
voting bloc in both 2008 and 2012 yet
some Democrats seem to be actually
working overtime to scare off as many
white male voters as possible oh he must
work the hole going forward
the way that I talked about our marriage
and also the way in which I acknowledge
the truth of the criticism that I have
enjoyed white privilege
absolutely undeniable I have been
arrested twice in my life those mistakes
or narrowing my options even old Joe
Biden is trying to play racial ketchup
he recently apologized to Anita Hill for
the whiteness of the Senate Judiciary
Committee there are a bunch of white
guys she faced a committee that didn't
fully understand what the hell is all
about to this day I regret I couldn't
come up with a way to get her a kind of
hearing she deserved
well the liberal media also keeps race
front and center they make no secret of
their belief that being white is a
negative when running for office is it
time to have somebody of color and a
woman and somebody younger or somebody
more establishment is it I think that be
that the Democrats across the country
are gonna help decide that but as a
white guy do you are you trying to
calculate whether or not this is the
right time for you they're obsessed well
the race and diversity focus undoubtedly
comes off too many Americans as deeply
unfair and itself kind of racist
now these voters proudly calls
themselves bitter clingers remember that
after the snarky 2008 Obama comment
about how fearful Americans were
clinging to their guns and religion well
Trump showed up in 2016 and appealed
directly to these forgotten Americans
The Forgotten men and women of our
country will be forgotten no longer
everyone is listening to you now so will
the deplorable z' feel more comfortable
with the democrats new self-appointed
spokesman for moral and cultural issues
if me being gay was a choice it was a
choice that was made far far above my
paygrade and that's the thing I wish the
Mike Pence's of the world would
understand if you got a problem with Who
I am
your problem is not with me your quarrel
sir is with my Creator
if there's a poll that shows that this
focus is on the top of any list of
voters concerns well let alone the
concerns of working-class Catholic and
evangelical voters I must have missed
that survey at least one Democrat who
knows a little bit about winning
national elections is warning that his
party is in danger with all these
intra-party litmus tests we start
sometimes creating what's called a
circular firing squad where you shot
shooting at your allies because one of
them is straying from purity on the
issues and when that happens typically
the overall effort and movement weakens
like reparations green New Deal that
kind of stuff there the Democrat
circular firing squad he was referencing
has caused even candidates who have the
best chance appealing to working-class
whites like Joe Biden to move far left
and there's let's face it there's zero
appetite now at this point for a
moderate like Howard Schultz that's not
happening
and of course the elephant in the room
in this entire debate about how the
Democrats can attract these
working-class voters is that the word
economy right it's painted on the side
of the big fat elephant in the room and
the economy according to pews latest
survey is still the number one issues
for Americans nationwide in a new Gallup
poll Trump scores 93 percent approval
with Republican voters on his handling
of the economy so how on earth are
Democrats gonna beat the strongest
economy in the g7 with record low
unemployment almost 500,000 new
manufacturing jobs created what's their
argument for beating that in the last 12
months wages have risen by 3.4 percent
and headlines like this we're just not
seen during eight years of Obama
blue-collar voters finally getting a
raise
workers are making more money so
Democrats what are they going to say
well they have caught it they have the
race they have socialism and they have
one other talking point left in their
manual um what about the economy for the
people who don't have the choices or
don't have the education that I have
unemployment that needs to look at at a
time of historic income inequality
should be asked to pay a greater share
we're talking about generational poverty
generational disposition you have a
nation of massive inequality markets
without words it's about the rich take
it all it's about the powerful get all
of it okay so it's income inequality
long-winded way of saying that this
argument is a loser we just for most
Americans are going up now not because
of government mandates but because of
Trump's policies what are they lower
taxes less regulation pressure on China
trade cheating and a tighter labor
market for all working people so the
Democrats answer is higher taxes more
regulations more low wage laborers
flooding into America that's exactly the
opposite of what most working-class
voters want
oh oh and for those liberals who put all
their hopes and being saved by changing
demography well here's a newsflash this
is the percentage of white non college
graduate boaters and a handful of key
states in Iowa they make up 62% of the
population
in Michigan 54% of the population Ohio
55% Pennsylvania 51% and Wisconsin 58
percent Trump does really well with that
group obviously now even a progressive
writer for The Atlantic noted the folly
of the demography will save us thinking
saying this is wishful thinking first
the US won't be majority minority and
about 2045 moreover even in 2040 37
states will remain majority white
today's radicalized democrat party has
moved further away from the voters they
need to win in 2020 they still have no
clue it's unbelievable really
how to speak to the working-class white
voters let alone how to get their votes
they look down they're elitist noses at
all working people of all backgrounds
and their values come on they pretty
much to look down their noses at
everything about the working-class
people and no slick advertising slogans
or campaigns or candidates who try to
out Christian the Trump pens ticket will
overcome the deep distrust that many
working-class Americans rightly filled
toward this 2020 Democrat field and
that's the angle